so if we treat fragments as mini
activities each with its own independent
life cycle in you why how does that
compare to the lifecycle of a real
activity well as you might expect the
basic life cycle events much the same as
the parent activity and as it moves
through the cycles of starts resumes
pauses and stops those same life cycle
events will be triggered within the
fragment itself so in most cases you can
simply move anything that you would have
put into the activities life cycle
handlers into the corresponding fragment
handles with of course a couple of
exceptions rather than building your UI
hearing on create fragments introduce a
new event specifically for this
oncreateview is where you construct or
inflate your UI hooked up to any data
sources and return it to the parent
activity which can then integrate it
into its view hierarchy there's a
corresponding ondestroy view handler
which is called immediately before the
fragment is added to the back stack
independent of the parent activity now
keep in mind that the fragment manager
can add any fragment transactions adding
removing or replacing fragments to the
back stack with a single parent
activities actives so a fragment can
move through this cycle multiple times
independent of the host activity so
ondestroy view is where you should clean
up any resources specifically related to
the UI such as bitmaps in memory cursors
to data anything like that
to help ensure that your app's memory
footprint isn't bloated by data that's
not needed when the fragment isn't
visible now as soon as the fragment is
returned from the back stack
oncreateview is called and you can
recreate the UI and reconnect data
sources before your fragment transitions
through the rest of the lifecycle to
become active again and because a
fragment can only exist within an
activity we also need callbacks to tell
us when a fragment is attached and
detached from its parent on attach is
your opportunity to get a reference to
the parent activity while on detach is
the last thing that happens even after
your fragment has technically been
destroyed now the final piece of the
puzzle is on activity created this
notifies our fragment that the parent
activity has completed it's on create
Handler and represents the point at
which we can safely interact with its UI
potentially including other fragment
now just like the activity lifecycle we
discussed in lesson three
once the fragment is no longer visible
there's a chance we'll be terminated
with no further code being executed that
can happen after onstop in the case of
the activity being terminated while the
fragment is part of that activity's view
hierarchy or after ondestroy view if the
fragment has already been placed in the
back stack once the activity is
destroyed